my name is lucas i go to gonzaga college
high school in dc
um i had a question regarding i had a
debate with my um
social justice teacher the other day
about um
now is that an actual class a mandatory
class yes
it's literally called justice yes so wow
okay and
it was it was about whether or not we
deserve
things and he was telling me that every
individual in the united states in the
world deserves
money through no work of their own
deserves money deserves health care
deserves food not just the access to it
but deserves to have it
and i was just wondering what you
thought about that because he was making
a lot of moral arguments
and saying that like yeah well i i mean
i think we all deserve
uh free ice cream every night and you
know unicorn to ride to work
i i guess i i would respond
first by asking him where where does
this entitlement come from
it's easy to say we deserve this and
that i would agree that
it's it would be nice for everyone to
have those things those are that's a
nice goal for everyone to be employed
for everyone to have a place to live
uh that's a it's a good goal for us to
achieve but the question is where does
he think those entitlements come from
he's probably not going to say god he'd
say like human dignity
yeah but then where does that come from
right and if he's not going to introduce
god into the equation
then at the end of the day you're left
with darwinianism which is dog-eat-dog
survival of the fittest you don't
deserve anything i mean you deserve
absolutely nothing
you deserve whatever you could take and
nothing more that's that's that's
probably the world view he's actually
working from that he doesn't want to
admit um so
that's the first question where do you
think these come from and the second
question is
even if i agree that everyone deserves
this or that um why does that
automatically mean
that the government why is the
government in the business of giving
people what they deserve because on a
moral level
i would say that i think it's true as a
christian
that everybody deserves a place to live
uh everyone deserves food
you know i think jesus would agree it's
pretty clear but
that doesn't mean that the government is
in the business
of giving people those entitlements
because the only way the government can
give anything to anyone is by taking it
from someone else
uh so then it becomes a sort of zero-sum
zero-sum game the only way for us to
give people what they deserve
is just through an act of love and and
charity
so